The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
In our lesson
today, we shall try
to find a relationship
between line
integrals and double integrals.
In particular, we shall
equate line integrals
along certain types
of closed curves
to double integrals
over the region enclosed
by the particular closed curve.
In particular, the
title of today's lecture
is Green's theorem.
And in terms of
some particulars,
I guess the intuitive notion
that we'll have to accept
is the idea of what one
means by a connected region.
I think this is one of those
times in mathematics where
we can say, if you have
an intuitive idea of what
the concept means, you
have the exact idea
of what the concept means.
Essentially, connected
means that you
can get from any
place in the region
to any other place in
the region without ever
having to leave the region.
It's as simple as that.
OK.
Connected means that you can
get from any point in the region
to any other point in the
region without ever having
to go outside the region.
The mathematician distinguishes
between two different types
of connected regions.
One of which is called
simply connected.
The other of which
being the opposite
of simply connected,
meaning non-simply
connected or multiply connected.
I prefer multiply connected
to non-simply connected,
because in non-simply connected
you don't know whether you're
modifying simply or connected.
A non-simply
connected region, when
you say multiply connected,
means that in particular
the region is connected.
The intuitive way of looking at
this is that simply connected
means no holes.
For example, this region
here is not only connected,
but it's simply connected.
There are no holes.
This region is connected.
You see I can get from any
point to any other point
without ever having
to leave the region.
But it's called
multiply connected,
because there are
holes in the region.
By the way, you see, the
trouble with using expressions
like holes versus non-holes, is
that in that particular case,
where we're dealing with
two or three dimensions
there's certainly no problem,
because we intuitively
visualize what a hole is.
In n-dimensional
space-- and we have
analogs of these results in
these n-dimensional space--
the problem is that how
do you describe a hole
without referring to a picture?
And the more rigorous
mathematical definition
of a simply connected region
is the following: the connected
region-- and it has to be
connected before you talk
about simply connected, you
see-- the connected region
R is called simply connected
if its complement is also
connected.
Remember the complement
is the portion
of space left when the
particular region is deleted.
For example, here we have
a simply connected region.
Notice that the
complement of this region
would be, for example,
the entire blackboard
with this piece missing.
And the entire blackboard
with this piece missing
is still a connected region.
On the other hand, if we were
to take this connected region
and look at its
complement, its complement
is this little hole together
with what's outside here.
And notice that there
is no way from getting
from here to here without having
to go outside the complement.
You see, in other
words, the complement
of the multiply connected
region is not connected.
At any rate, whichever way you
want to look at this, is fine.
Think of simply
connected, at least
in the two-dimensional
case, as meaning no holes.
And with this as background,
Green's theorem--
call it the theorem, I
guess-- is stated as follows.
Suppose R is simply connected
with a boundary C. Notice,
R is the region.
C is its boundary.
And a very interesting
thing takes place.
If you form the line integral
around the boundary C,
and by the way, with
this loop in here,
this is the symbol that we
mean around the closed curve.
The arrow head is simply done
to invoke the convention--
and we do have to
pick a convention,
just like we did in calculus
of a single variable
about positive and
negative and how
you move-- we pick the
positive direction as being
the direction in which one
goes around the boundary
so that the region
appears to our left
as we go around the boundary.
As we're going around here,
you see, in this direction,
the region appears to our left.
At any rate, I'll mention
that in more detail later.
The directed line integral
around closed curve C,
M*dx plus N*dy turns out to be a
double integral over the region
R enclosed by the curve.
And that double integral
has as its integrand
the partial of N with respect
to x minus the partial of M
with respect to y.
And I will refer to this
again very, very shortly.
But I hope that this
rings a familiar bell
in terms of what we talked
about exact differentials.
Remember, a differential
M*dx plus N*dy was exact
if the partial of N with respect
to x equaled the partial of M
with respect to y.
I'll return to that in a moment.
For the time being,
all I want you to see
is what Green's theorem says.
What Green's theorem does is
it relates a line integral
along the boundary of a
simply connected region
to a double integral
over the region itself.
The proof of the theorem
is in the Thomas text.
It's available in a pretty
straightforward form
for anybody who would like to
see the proof of the result.
I don't think I want to prove
the result in this lecture.
I think I would rather hammer
home what the theorem says,
rather than what this
rigorous proof is.
The idea is, though, that what?
A line integral is related
to a multiple integral.
And all that's required
for Green's theorem
to be true is that M, N, the
partial of M with respect to y,
the partial of N
with respect to x
must exist and be continuous
in a region containing R.
And we'll see later that
even the condition of simply
connected can be waived.
In fact, in the
Thomas demonstration,
we don't even deal with the
most general simply connected
regions.
He gives his proof for
a very specific type
of simply connected region.
But again, that
isn't crucial either.
We'll talk about that in more
detail later in the lecture
as well as in the exercises.
The idea again though is what?
We're not relating
arbitrary line integrals
to arbitrary multiple integrals.
But Green's theorem
relates a line integral
along the boundary of a
simply connected region
to a double integral
defined on the interior
of the closed curve
C, the region R.
And there are two
interesting cases.
One of which-- well, there
are more than two, but two
that we'd like to talk about.
One of the interesting
cases we've already hinted
at and that is if M*dx
plus N*dy is exact,
then the integral of M*dx plus
N*dy around the closed curve C
is 0.
And the reason
for this, you see,
is that the integral
around the closed curve,
by Green's theorem, is just
a double integral partial N
with respect to x minus
partial M with respect to y.
And if M*dx plus N*dy is exact,
then these two terms are equal
so that their difference
is identically 0.
And to integrate 0*dA over
any region R, of course,
is just 0 itself.
In other words, then, if
M*dx plus N*dy is exact,
the integral around
any closed curve is 0.
And by the way, this
ties in with a question
that was raised in
our previous lecture.
And that was we saw that if
we had a force for example,
and we had a particle move from
the point P_0 to the point P_1
under the influence
of that force,
that the work done as that
particle moved in general
depended on the curve
which connected P_0 to P_1.
My claim is that if the
force, M*i plus N*j has as its
components-- see M and N-- where
the partial of M with respect
to y equals the partial
of N with respect x.
My claim is, under
those conditions,
the work is independent
of the path.
And that's what we mean in turn
by a conservative force field.
The proof is quite simple.
What we do is we pick
two different paths
that connect P_0 to P_1.
We call one of the paths
C_1 and the other path C_2.
And now, what we're
saying is, if we
think of C as being
the curve that
keeps this region to our
left as we go along here,
then the integral around C is 0.
But what is the
integral around C?
It's the integral along C_1
minus the integral along C_2.
And I hope that that's
clear from the exercises
of last time.
That when you switch the
sense of the path, all you do
is change the sign
of the integrand.
In fact, by the way, while we're
on that topic, let's digress
for a moment and return to our
statement of Green's theorem
and observe that if we were
to switch the convention,
if we want to switch
the convention,
and keep the positive
direction as that which
kept the area on
our right, notice
that this would change
the sense here, which
should give me a minus sign.
But if I interchange, you
see, the order of the terms
here, if I reverse
the sense, the sign
of the integral, the double
integral, will also change.
The important point being that
all of these sign conventions
are preserved by things like
Green's theorem and the like.
But the important point is,
getting back to this now,
the integral around
the closed curve C
is the integral along C_1
minus the integral along C_2.
And since the integral along
that closed curve is 0,
it says that this
minus this is 0.
Consequently, these two
integrals are equal.
And since C_1 and
C_2 are arbitrary
paths that connect
P_0 and P_1, that
shows that the line integral,
in this particular case,
does not depend on the path,
but only the points P_0 and P_1.
Again, we will emphasize
that more in the exercises.
The second interesting
application of Green's theorem
is a form which
not only shows us
how a line integral and a
multiple integral are related,
but it actually shows us a way
of computing an area in terms
of a line integral.
In particular, if
in Green's theorem
we let N equal x and
M equal negative y,
notice that Green's
theorem then becomes what?
The integral along
a closed curve C,
M*dx plus N*dy is just
minus y*dx plus x*dy.
The partial of N with
respect to x is 1.
The partial of M with
respect to y is minus 1.
Therefore the partial
with N with respect
to x minus the partial of
M with-- the partial of N
with respect to x minus the
partial of M with respect to y
is 1 minus minus 1, which is 2.
In other words,
Green's theorem says
that the integral around the
closed curve, in this case,
is twice the area of the region
R. You see, without the 2
in here, this would just be
the area of the region R.
Since 2 is a constant
factor, we can take it
outside the integral sign.
In other words, in
terms of a picture,
if I want to find the
area of the region R,
and I want to use
a line integral,
I need only take one
half of this integral.
In other words, the area
of the region R is one half
the integral around the
boundary of R, x*dy minus y*dx.
And again, I will drill
on that in the homework.
The one remaining thing
I wanted to point out
before we go to a
specific example
is how we remove the
restriction of the region being
simply connected.
You see, what I claim
is that we may replace
simply connected by connected.
Since multiply
connected regions are
unions of simply connected ones
with cuts, whatever that means.
Let me show you what
I'm saying here.
Look at this multiply
connected region here.
What I'm saying is, suppose
I were to cut this region,
I can then visualize this as the
union of two simply connected
regions.
In fact, if I have a piece
of paper in my pocket,
I think we might as well-- the
entire two parts of calculus
are almost over, and I've never
done an experiment for you.
Here's one I think
even I can handle.
Here's a connected region.
It's a piece of paper.
I'll fold it.
And I'll now make it.
It's simply connected, because
there are no holes in it.
I will now undo that.
I will make the region connected
but now multiply connected.
You see, there's a hole in it.
And all I'm saying is,
if I cut this region,
not necessarily along
a straight line.
All I've got to do is to cut it.
If I cut this region,
then what I have
are two simply
connected regions that
can be viewed as being
fit together this way.
But to see them clearly,
we can just separate them.
But the reason I wanted
to cut them for you
is to see that I can
actually fit these together.
And notice that
the cut that joins
these two, from a
theoretical point of view,
has no thickness.
Right?
That's just a line
that joins these two.
And here's the key point.
You see physically, certainly if
I put a cut inside the region,
the resulting picture is
different than with the cut
missing.
In other words, I can
distinguish between the shape
that I've drawn without the
accentuated chalk mark in here
and the shape that I have
with the accentuated chalk
mark in here.
But here's the key point.
First of all, as far as
computing a double area
is concerned, the cut, having
no thickness, has zero area.
So if somehow I were to compute
the area of the region R
without the cut, I would
expect to get the same area.
Or if I were to
compute whatever you
want to call this, the
density or what have you,
if I want to compute the mass
of the region R with the cut,
it should be the same as
the mass without the cut,
because the difference
is essentially what?
A set of points
which has zero area.
And by the way, for
those of you who
may read ahead in mathematics
and have heard such expressions
as Lebesgue integrals, the
Lebesgue integral and the like.
These are things defined
on sets of measure 0.
What these things mean from
an intuitive point of view
is essentially what
we're talking about now.
You see here are infinitely
many points on this cut.
And yet the important thing
is that with respect to area
these points, even though
they're infinite in number,
contribute no area.
In other words,
there are infinitely
many points on a line, but
a line having no thickness
has no area.
So certainly, putting
the cut in does not
affect the double integral.
On the other hand,
since we always
assumed that the region is kept
on our left as we go around,
it turns out that from the
single integral, the line
integral point of
view, each cut cancels
because of opposite sense.
What I'm saying is, if I take
this region and slice it,
you see, how do I
traverse this piece?
Since I want the area to
be enclosed on my left,
I traverse this region in
this particular direction.
When it comes to this piece,
I traverse this region
in this direction so that the
area is enclosed to my left.
When I now superimpose
these two, what happens
is, since this line integral
and this line integral
go exactly over the same curve,
remember I just separated these
so I could see them better,
when I push these together,
this is the same line.
Since they have the same
function, the same points,
but only opposite sense,
these two integrals cancel.
In other words, if I'm
given a region that's
multiply connected, I
can view it like this,
meaning I go around
this piece this way
so that my region is on my left.
I go around the
outside border this way
so that the region
is on my left.
And when I want to
use Green's theorem,
all I do is essentially,
I don't even
have to make the two cuts here,
I could even make one cut.
And look at this
as the union of--
See, well, the two is-- see,
if I make just the one cut
and leave the line out,
there are no longer any holes
in the region here.
But that's not the
important point.
The important point is that to
visualize the integral that I
want, or the regions that
I want, all I have to do
is put the cut in.
And whatever the cut
does is canceled out
in the statement
of Green's theorem.
In other words, again,
that quite often
in using Green's
theorem, we still
apply it to multiply
connected regions.
The reason that we
stress simply connected
is that the proofs that are
given for Green's theorem
are easiest to handle
in the case of simply
connected regions.
And then we simply generalize
it to multiply connected
by pointing out what we just
did here, that we can always
visualize a multiply connected
region as a union of simply
connected regions if the
appropriate cuts are made.
And again, that will be
emphasized in the exercises.
I thought that what we should
do to finish off today's lesson
would be to actually
do a trivial exercise.
By trivial, I mean
Green's theorem
has profound application.
It's more than just
relating line integrals
to multiple integrals.
The applications of these
things are enormous.
And we're going to hit a few
of these in the exercises.
But what I wanted to do was to
pick sort of a straightforward
example just to have you see
what Green's theorem means
when we translate into
a concrete situation.
And the example I have
in mind is simply this.
Let's compute the line integral
around the closed curve C,
y cubed dx plus x to the
fourth dy, where the curve
C happens to be the following
simply closed, or closed curve.
I start at the origin and
move to the point (1, 1)
along the parabola
y equals x squared.
Then I moved from (1, 1) to (0,
1) along the line y equals 1.
And then I move from
(0, 1) down to (0, 0)
along the line x equals 0.
The boundary of this is what I'm
calling my region C, my curve
C. Notice that the region R
enclosed by C lies on my left
as I traverse the boundary
of C. And what I want to do
is to find the value
of this line integral
along this particular
closed curve C.
And again, if you
want to see this
in terms of our lecture of
last time, where we talked
about work and force,
imagine that my force
is defined in the xy-plane,
at any point (x, y),
to be y cubed i plus x to
the fourth j, et cetera.
Meaning dR, as usual,
will be dx*i plus dy*j.
And what we're saying is
that this particular integral
represents the work that would
be done if a particle were
starting at the point (0, 0) and
being moved along the curve C
so that it returns
to the point (0, 0).
Now keep in mind, merely
because the particle
is returning to the
same point from which it
started is not enough to
guarantee that the work done is
0.
In fact, the guarantee
that would be necessary
would be that the partial
of y cubed with respect to y
would have to be identical to
the partial of x to the fourth
with respect x.
And that certainly
isn't the case
in this particular example.
We don't have a conservative
force field in this case.
In this case, we suspect
that the work done
should depend on the path
connecting the points.
In particular, if we go
around a closed path,
the work done would
not have to be 0.
At any rate, that's
enough lip service
paid to the physical
interpretation of this.
Let's actually try to
solve this problem.
And what we're going to do
is solve it in two ways.
The first way will be to
emphasize Green's theorem.
We'll solve it first
by Green's theorem,
because that is the
sermon for today.
And the second method
will be to show
how we would have solved
the same problem if we
didn't have Green's theorem.
The idea being, I won't tell
you which of the two ways
one should have done this.
The important point
from our point of view
is that the two methods
yield the same answer.
At any rate, to use
Green's theorem,
notice that M is y cubed.
N is equal to x to the fourth.
So the statement
of Green's theorem,
which says that the integral
around the closed curve C,
M*dx plus N*dy is the double
integral around the region
enclosed by C, the partial
of N with respect to x minus
the partial of M with
respect to y, dA.
That leads to this.
And now, what is my region A?
I'll think of it
as being a dy*dx.
And if I look at my
region a, I observe
that for a fixed value of
x, y varies from the curve
x squared to 1.
And x, in turn, varies
any place from 0 to 1.
So the line integral that
I'm trying to evaluate
is this particular
double integral.
By the way, we don't
really need this,
what comes next,
because from here on in,
this should be old hat.
But just by way
of review, notice
that I could have written this
with the order of integration
reversed, so that
I wouldn't have
to worry about an x
squared in the lower limit.
I might like all of my
lower limits to be zero.
Notice I could have
picked a horizontal strip
and shown that for
a fixed value of y,
x varies from 0 to
the square root of y.
And y varies from 0 to 1.
In any event, this
is just garnishing.
This is the easy part.
All I'm saying is,
we now evaluate
this iterated integral,
integrating with respect to x.
The integrand becomes x
to the fourth minus 3x y
squared evaluated
between x equals 0,
and x equals the
square root of y.
That, of course, leads to y
squared minus 3 y to the 5/2.
I integrate that
between 0 and 1.
I get 1/3 y cubed
minus 6/7 y to the 7/2.
And as y goes from 0 to 1,
this becomes minus 11/21.
By the way, again, I hope it's
clear from previous exercises
that the minus sign simply
has physical significance.
That all we're saying
is, is that one
would expect that if
the motion takes place
in the direction of
the force, the force is
helping us move the particle.
Whereas if the force is
taking place opposite
to the direction
of motion, we have
to push against the force
to get the particle there.
So what we're saying is in one
case, the sense is positive.
The other is negative.
I'm not going to
worry here physically
about what the meaning
of the minus sign is.
But using Green's theorem,
we have shown what?
That the integral
around the closed curve
C, as we've defined C before,
y cubed dx plus x fourth dy,
is minus 11/21.
And what I would like to do
now, to finish today's lesson,
is to do the same
problem, only doing it
without Green's theorem.
And again, the point
is to do this problem
without using Green's theorem.
Remember what my
region was over here.
Without having to refer
back to the previous work.
What I'm doing is my curve C
consists of three separate line
integrals.
C_1 is the curve y equals x
squared as x goes from 0 to 1.
C_2 is the curve y equals 1,
where x varies from 1 to 0.
And the curve C_3 is x equals
0, and y varying continuously
from 1 to 0.
At any rate, using
the fact that,
if a curve is the
union of curves,
that the line integral
around that curve
is the sum of the integral over
the curves making up the union.
I get that the line
integral along C,
y cubed dx plus x
to the fourth dy,
is the sum of these
three line integrals.
In other words, I integrate
along C_1, C_2, and C_3,
where C_1 is y equals x squared.
And x varies
continuously from 0 to 1.
C_2 is the line y equals 1.
And x varies
continuously from 1 to 0.
C_3 is the line x equals 0.
And y varies
continuously from 1 to 0,
using the concepts
that we talked about
in the last lecture.
For example, to evaluate this
integral, this will be what?
I replace y by x squared, dy by
2x*dx and integrate as x goes
from 0 to 1.
So my first integral is
simply integral from 0 to 1,
x to sixth dx plus x to
the fourth times 2x*dx.
My second integral, coming back
to here, y is constantly 1.
All right.
So dy is 0.
That makes this term drop out.
Consequently, this
term becomes what?
1*dx, as x varies
continuously from 1 to 0.
So that integral becomes
integral 1 to 0 dx.
And my final integral,
over C_3, notice,
for that integral x is 0.
So both this term and
this term drop out.
See x is 0.
So this term drops out.
The fact that x is a
constant makes dx equal to 0.
So this term drops out.
So my integrand is just
0*dy as y goes from 1 to 0.
And to make a long
story short here,
this integrand is simply
x to the sixth plus 2x
to the fifth dx from 0 to 1.
This is simply another
way of writing minus 1.
This is 0.
So my line integral
along the closed curve C
is 1/7 x to the seventh
plus 1/3 x to the sixth,
evaluated between
0 and 1, minus 1.
This comes out to be a 1/7 plus
1/3, which is 10/21 minus 1
makes this minus 11/21.
And hopefully, that
checks with the answer
that we got by the
previous method.
And at any rate,
if nothing else,
that is an application as to
how Green's theorem works.
Now what this does as far as
this lecture is concerned,
and the exercises
will bring this out,
is it ties in line integrals
with multiple integrals.
That will be the last lecture
of this particular block
of material.
And in the next
lesson, what we will do
is introduce a new
block of material.
We in particular shall
talk about complex numbers.
And that will occupy
us for a little while.
And at any rate though,
until next time, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.